gee Walters did you meet you leave me
alone
[Applause]
what we want to know what didn't you
know you met your husband in a club
the whole concept of cha-cha falling
apart why you asking me all these
questions
[Applause]
Downton comes apart
[Applause]
is that one of those things where you
thought you were famous till you were in
Downton no I didn't think that at all
it's every since Downton that people
seem to know you know who who stopped me
and announcement but it's only since
Downton and that's that's television for
you yes it's common I was I was in
waitress in storing tonight favorite
little boy was at the checkout with his
mother and he kept looking at me and I
thought what am I gonna do but and he
won't kept looking at me and looking at
me and I said okay can I help you and he
said it's all right it'll come to me in
a minute
[Laughter]
but the the people coming up to you now
like because very Americans are very
well America you know they're not shy
Americans no but I don't go anywhere
really where they can't get at me you
still go clubbing do so cutter Rob you
know I've never ever been to a club in
my life
you like a rock oh do I yes never been
to a nightclub yes you have I didn't you
in heaven
[Applause]
[Applause]
is that really the oldies home yes did
you know have a nice night
you look like you're having fun I've
never been to share what you were there
to see share the singer share there's a
camera right yeah I'm talking to you
yep so if I'm naturally talking to you
by two eyes are on you here and we're
talking mm-hmm in a camera I move over
to there and my other eye is in the
camera but I'm looking at you
[Music]
why have you don't blink unless you they
got something in your eye yeah I don't
have to blink added a trick told me they
told me that yeah I was at a birthday
party for Liza Minnelli and her
godmother was Marlena Dietrich and then
she saw me and I was just sort of famous
as Elfi or something you know no and she
knew who I was and she said to me she
said you're supposed to be a movie star
why are you dressed so scruffy Lee and
she started giving me a Bulacan about
dressing and there was a buffet and she
said there's a buffet let's have dinner
so I said okay all right okay I said
coming in we're going to she said no you
choose I said what do you want said
whatever you have I'll have it and then
I sat down and she said and another
thing you're using the wrong ice and
then she told me that story hmm it's
amazing and then someone else had never
link people don't like that when you
blink no never but whatever the reason
okay you can you can make comments yeah
I talk to you without blinking the
entire time
you can still say it backwards super
kind of argistix yes you want to hear it
if you can if I can what do you mean if
I can dosha Sally X mystic tragically
ruthless
[Applause]
I read somewhere you talked about your
least favorite kisser walls but I won't
ask for that but who would you lose your
best the best kisser Oh question um you
mean stage you know theater did I mean
kissing you know we so often as actors
especially actually met more in the
theater but also in auditions for you
know film things you walk in and okay
you and you have to immediately be very
intimate if it's not actually kissing
it's touching it's hugging with someone
who you've literally met 30 seconds ago
so you know we get to be able to do that
things that other people would just feel
so embarrassed and weird we have to be
able to go there it's really hard it's
really awful isn't it when you when you
it's like you're done kissing somebody
hi I'm Paul but Paul your longest spin
kiss was with someone very unlikely
wasn't it the most kisses I've had in a
movie was with your hero Jack now many
many times
[Applause]
I would he played my father in a film
called how do you know and the
relationship that we had that James L
Brooks the director wanted to portray
was that of a very loving father and son
and no matter what kind of stress we
were under or what the conflicts in our
relationship was we would always kiss
each other hello and goodbye and James
Brooks likes to film a scene 70 times
need be or even if you don't need to
he'll still do it so we just would
always kiss on the nips mm-hmm it was
great but when I first met him I was
going to rehearse with Jack Nicholson
and I was very nervous because I'd never
seen the man in person let alone you
know he had never met him and and I was
a huge fan and and when he showed up to
the rehearsal he he walked in he looked
at me grabbed me
this is what Jack Nicholson did I was
sitting you're me I'll be Jack Nicholson
and he came excuse me listen he came in
watch Cities
[Applause]
[Music]
of Ian as Coriolanus we are look at that
my lord
Wolverine eat your heart you do look
great there in but check out Patrick
Stewart you've been hearing about this
amazing body it it is absolutely amazing
the privilege to be so close but you
know magneto the character I used to
play in this tie though Francois was
also pretty a muscular it wasn't here
and there you can see but the trick is
that I am wearing underneath my costume
a suit which is sculpted to look as if
I've put on it because he did you know
workout McKellen's working man just put
on the suit I'll tell you what I've
still got it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you two got drinks and I don't give
we've got red wine red wine psychic and
red wine people what's all this about
you being circumcised you work together
you work together all on board well you
did two places together on projects are
brilliant oh yes you know that there are
not many plays where there are two
wonderful parts for actors of the same
age so you can go through your life
never working with the people you admire
and the people who you should have an
awful lot in common with Shakespeare is
not bad it to that extent but there are
a few pairs and one of them is wait you
forgot oh and there are two wonderful
parts for people of the same age and
another one is no man's land by Harold
Pinter and we've done them both and
we've just finished doing no man's land
in London though don't despair if you
missed it you can catch it on NT live
they record a performance and I have
just had an idea this is awesome for for
some time now I have been teasing Hugh
but getting more and more serious about
a theatre work job we might do together
I have been saying to this man for a
long time he should play Stephen
Sondheim's Sweeney Todd it is if the
role might have been written for him and
I add a rider that if he plays Sweeney
Todd I will for a limited run played the
judge which is a two scene role but with
two numbers including a duet between the
two of them who should play mrs. Lovett
[Applause]
[Music]